now he's uh banging hotties wearing
Rolexes and I might have a slight
cocaine addiction a lot of ups and downs
when he has a rough set he gets
challenged by a competitor who tries to
beat him he's undefeated all time while
being challenged this is a week off for
him after a few solid appearances you
guys know the words to the song
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
it's good to be here at the start of the
race Wars uh there was a
horrible incident in Montgomery Alabama
where a black man was arrested for
hitting white people with chairs which I
think is unfair because I've been
watching white people hit each other
with chairs on TV this whole time
I thought that's just how they said
hello you know
pro wrestling
um
I uh love the whites I think it's great
that Republicans are out here fighting
for the rights I pick Republicans have a
great chance because Republicans aren't
afraid of anything except for communism
and terrorism and abortion gay marriage
trans people
foreign
I'm a huge humanitarian I like to do a
lot of community service every weekend I
go to my local Lululemon and I buy out
all the extra large yoga pants
because no one wants to see that [__]
all right thank you
all right
with the new minute got better as it
went along started off with a very
crusty joke about white people hitting
each other with chairs literally explain
it afterwards by saying the words
professional wrestling
yeah I thought a lot of people would
know about pro wrestling but I guess it
wasn't clear that it was about that's
not the problem
[Laughter]
true I did not know what you were
talking about and I know jokes and pro
wrestling and even I could not figure
out exactly what you meant uh how do you
feel Hans how did that feel for you I
feel like that was kind of rough and fun
at the same time who do you think you
should be challenged by next week after
a performance like that who do you think
your opponent should be I've always
chose your opponent who would you like
to go against
um maybe another [__] probably
[Music]
Christ
INE
I don't know I think somebody fell pulse
Malone in uh so uh he has beaten uh
people that are mentally challenged
before uh that are very very funny
physically you've been on before yes he
doesn't look strong enough to take him
this is the first time he does a new
minute every week everybody else in the
bucket they could be they could have
gotten on again well I wasn't paid to be
here I don't know how I got here but I'm
having a great time so far
I'm a huge fan of you thank you very
much
[Applause]
how does it feel having a rusty set in
front of post Malone one of your
favorite musical artist I feel like I'm
a post regular now oh [__] you know what
I think I don't know I feel like you
should have a hard challenge I think we
should scare some life in you I think
next week you should battle Casey rocket
for
regular Chef I think we gotta do it
I think Joe just said that might be it
oh yeah does he want to do it I mean oh
look how does he want to do
fame money why would anyone want to take
part in such a thing
seems like a lone wolf that guy
um but no I uh I would love to challenge
Casey rocket I think that'd be a great
challenge thanks for the suggestion
there you go it's happening next week
Hans Kim vs Casey rock at a battle of
life and death could be the [__] one
Hans thank you so much way to get the
show started you're out of here we're
going to the bucket now wait did we get
the thing back where'd it go
[Music]
that was Hans Kim that was Hanscom
where's the [__] bucket up